[Music]
good afternoon good morning good evening
wherever the hell you are in the world
and welcome to sidetrack on sci-fi
sunday your sci-fi tv and movie channel
today
i want to join again
oh someone's repeated i i had a shout
out i
we're in a different time zone that's
what happened you know
it gets interesting over here there we
go that's fine
so this week we are again
joined by harris from mccubed and stormy
who however much i stop inviting him he
keeps turning up anyway he gave me the
code i'm always in i'm like
like we would have it any other way
as long as there's a code
exactly absolutely
we um i i'm pretty sure a couple of
weeks ago we said we weren't going to
talk about work again
i'm pretty sure there was a comment
no more woke because it makes i get
angry stormy gets angry
um and then everything goes on
but instead we're going to talk about
the ring of power or the rings of power
and the lord of the rings
um because people are very angry
there have been comments
go won't go broke
i don't quite understand it but
we'll get stuck into it so
i'm gonna go the very first of all
these books were written in the 30s
they were based on norse mythology so
there isn't a lot of color in the
original movies there's a handful of of
black or ethnic minority whatever you
want to call it um actors they're just
there just isn't many
um when we see the elves all lining up
it's a sea of pink faces it just is
um there's a handful in the hobbit
but but there's not a great deal
and there was a little bit of an issue
in the hobbit when one of the casting
directors did say one of the actors skin
was a little bit too dark to appear in
hobbit and um and so there was a little
bit of a controversy um but so so so
that's it
we've seen the advert
guys what do you think what first of all
i'm just going to ask you the question
now
do you think it's reasonable for people
to be this angry and a lot of people are
really angry about this over something
they haven't seen yet
yes i would say that would be
unreasonable
i thought you're going to say it's very
reasonable
it's perfectly reasonable and like uh a
sonic the hedgehog kind of case
you know we're not recreating a cgi
character it's it's
a damn show
it's it's people walking around
you know yeah
it's
so unnecessary yeah there's no way to
judge it without seeing something you
know
i don't think
i get a lot of comments on the channel
about it's going to go woke they've
ruined lords of the rings and my
response has always been
we've not seen it yet how can you say
they've ruined lord of the rings and
we've not seen it yet
um we've seen
two 30 seconds adverts
two clips
right now two trailers i
because yeah there's an extended one
shown at comic con this uh past week
and i mean i think in total we have
about four minutes of uh
original screen time and throw out all
the trailers
maybe four
yeah
uh and it's going to be um
it can't be any worse than seriously
game of thrones that's true
it ended so badly i i could get to the
end of game of thrones
i've been watching this for eight years
eight freaking years of my life i've
been watching this crap it has been
amazing
so what was your reaction to season
eight was uh daenerys's uh freak out
sort of fizzled out to nothing really
happened was more the thing that was
not it was just a very unconvincing end
but anyway let's not talk about game of
thrones we've got other things we've got
a bigger fish to fry
so
that could be another video um
so this is actually going to be out soon
isn't it this is out in like what six
weeks
something like that yeah really um it's
going to be
50 hours of television if all goes to
plan
let's judge it in three minutes and 55
seconds please
let's judge it on on on some images
where people can't even speak radio um
so i mean a lot of people angry right
stormy you've had it you've had to think
about why are actually people
angry about this and trying to break it
down for us do you want to do you want
to give us a quick thumbnail
yeah i mean
for whatever reason i did a deep dive on
and collected the seven main kind of
[ __ ] points that um
hate bait on youtube uh and twitter and
tumblr and facebook all
you know [ __ ] about
tumblr that place where guys go to meet
other guys yeah
yeah
so anyway
the first one is
terrible dialogue
we've seen three minutes and 59 yeah
how's
50 50 hours of broadcast television
and you know
there's not a lot of dialogue when most
of it you know is sweeping landscapes
har foot's trampling through the woods
you know climbing up all the rocks you
know it's just
you know ball rocks don't have a lot of
lines in this so i mean
you know
anyway
right yeah
their first [ __ ] point is terrible
dialogue which kind of
rolls over into
the other [ __ ] point was
the writers have no narrative skills
again
they are very inexperienced writers yeah
we can we can agree on that uh i've
written their names down somewhere
patrick mckay and jd payne
their mates that have known each other
for years and years and years
their only real credit
really is a film that hasn't been
released yet because they wrote star
trek four
um and apparently that impressed jeff
bezos so much he gave them this
well i mean
bezos was the judge interesting
and to be fair
what was uh peter jackson's credits
previously taught me that
um
he didn't i i don't i couldn't tell you
but he didn't have much under his belt
he only had one or two projects
bad habits which was a with a movie
basically made on his own wasn't it with
him but those aliens and
at one point alien goes up through with
a chainsaw through the other end
so
not a great deal and what was and you
know he made let's see let's look at his
uh stuff before that it was the
frighteners
which is correct to be fine i love that
yeah yeah yeah and there was another one
that was just the when i um
heavenly creatures okay that some people
saw that but when i first ran across uh
uh jackson was in a movie called dead
alive
homegrown
indie new zealand film
and harris you you've got to track this
down
live
it had been the highest amount of stage
blood ever used in any type of i mean it
was a volcano it was kind of a stick
horror film
but i mean he used like volcanoes of
blood i mean there was blood everywhere
wasn't it
and so huh it was called bad habits when
it was released here in the uk at first
it had several it's had several names
through different distribution deals and
in different uh places
uh i'm not sure his brain dead i think
was the other one that i thought
here in the united states is called dead
a lot but the brain dead was the i think
the international release title i'm
looking
uh but but anyway
so tristar you know let's go back you
know wind the clock back 20 some years
when tristar
ordered all three
and to the guy
that wrote directed dead [ __ ] alive
i mean what the hell were they thinking
i mean they definitely saw something in
peter jackson
you know and uh
you know in frighteners which was
a movie you know but
i mean you know it was um the
frightening
he had to have come to him with a plan
or something
well yeah i mean he had uh i mean
jackson pitched him with a whole video
as you know with pre-production going on
and he had the he'd already made these
huge scale models that he called
bigoters
and a venice tariff
really
yes oh yeah if you go back
to uh some of the uh lord of the rings
uh
dvd notes and uh special uh features
there's he chronicles all of this
you know but uh you know so the biggest
thing he'd made to date before tristar
picked this up was uh frighteners with
michael j fox and if you watch the
frighteners you will see
where the ring race costume comes
because the ghosts spirits were
almost identical to the nazcal god
my favorite thing in the frighteners is
when it's the sergeant major um oh he's
such a great actor and i forgot his name
all right he always plays drill
sergeants and he plays the dual charging
ghost
in that and then it's our brilliant film
um how much i need
but yeah so i mean that that's that's
very it does seem strange to me that
they've given the biggest tv project in
history to two virtual unknowns but jeff
bezos
is a huge tolkien fan
and there's a story about um one of his
teachers saying that at 12 years old he
did a um he did like a presentation
about how awesome the hobbit was and the
book obviously
um and they were blown away by it but
apparently it went on for
ages
and that he went on and on and on about
it so here's a talk about
he but these writers they had to pitch
to
executives amazon and they had to pitch
some family because the family had final
word on almost yet
you know and and they had to get through
the same process pitch process that
jackson did
you know and they were harder on jackson
because you know dead alive no one's
really heard of him outside really
unless you're a film geek outside of new
zealand
and um
i mean you know they put them no pun
intended through the ringer
and
uh
you know bezos yeah loves him some lord
of the rings but he's not going to spend
what a quarter billion dollars on just
the damn license
to see that fail
and
billion quid i spend
so i believe
and according to
other tolkien scholars that's met the
writing team met the producers met the
showrunners everybody creatively
responsible
seem quite happy
with what they've produced that have
actually seen
you know some of the work you know
seeing a few of the first episodes
tom shippy who is one tolkien scholar
we'll go back to what the hell is a
talking scholar in a second he was so
excited to probably see him back in 2019
he went on uh youtube and talked about
it and got himself sacked
um because he told that he said a little
bit too much information but let's just
just just quickly
a token scholar are you talking
absolutely why did you get a degree in
tokenism
actually you you get a degree in a like
a phd in uh literature
um like there's people who've got phds
in literature and study and become a
scholar of shakespeare or there's p
there's a
phds in literature for uh poe
you know you typically you got to do
your dissertation on some writer if
you're going to get a phd
literature historic literature blah blah
blah blah you know so that's what they
mean by this yeah he's probably doing
his dissertation or something like that
and
from reason about this i'm sure we'll
get into it more later about what
they've set this series on but there is
a lot of information
as there seems to be and tolkien wrote
he didn't just write the books he then
wrote a lot of other stuff to go with it
but we'll come back to that okay
just put a pin
in this thing that the writing's bad i
think we is it fair to say
it's it's crap because we've only seen
three or four adverts so how can you and
and there's people that actually say a
great thing there so how can we
remotely say that
that
the new comic-con trailer looked badass
honestly
the the new honest i was very skeptic
going in
just because you know
it's two writers we don't know but after
the first
trailer i i got a little more excited
and after this last one i'm i'm i'm in
there there's nothing that looks odd or
awful about it to me at all it looks
interesting
how if you do look like a bloke that
would say stoked i was disappointed that
you didn't go i'm stoked man i'm like
dude come on
i am stoked for it though i am
thank you i appreciate that i'm keeping
that
okay what else is on the list then so we
can
move on back to the trailer thing you
know i saw when i first saw the trailer
for the matrix
million years ago
you know i was like
what a load of crap
you know because the trailer just showed
a bunch of special effects all kind of
tied together as some hacker dude
right like what is this what the
what is this [ __ ]
and there was i was in
this was back in the days of aol
i was in some uh i think i was in
keyword hollywood online we're talking
about movies and someone said dude
you've got to go see the matrix i said i
saw the trailer
no you've got to go see it okay [ __ ]
fine
so i went out and seen it totally blown
away
because the trailer
what had almost literally nothing to do
with the storyline that was the matrix
i see all these people you know what
trying to get hate clicks on youtube
with just judging the trailer which is
usually directed by somebody else or put
together by a marketing team or
something not the storytellers because
they're busy making actual episodes yeah
you know how that [ __ ] goes yeah
yeah yeah yeah and it was
totally separate
from what the actual movie was now if
they did a trailer on what the actual
movie was i'd have been freaked out all
you know beforehand
but i had to get a friend to
they have to tell me no don't they film
like that has to be dumbed down for the
trail
and they have to get people to try to
get bums in season but you know you know
what's worse than a trailer that just
when you get a trailer and a film i
remember filming it was a ryan reynolds
movie years ago and um that smell the
fart actress was in it kristen stewart
isn't it
it's based around a fun fair or a
um something like that and it's it's a
team drama
but ryan reynolds had just done a comedy
and come out of a comedy so and there's
a few little clips in it i think jesse
eisenberg was in it as well
um
and that sort of film was popular at the
time so they advertised it like a teen
comedy like american pie or something
it's the only film i've ever walked out
in the cinema
um during
the
yeah i wanted so i was going to demand
my money back advertisement pissed me
off but anyway irrelevant um
so what okay so what was next on the
list so the next one on their [ __ ] list
is
really low effort costumes and sets
like it cost a billion credit
cards
like
oh my god and that big yeah it's just
are you kidding me i mean have you you
know like um
some of the elves costumes is actually
like
leaves i mean it's really ornate you
know and
it was
you know you could see how
at least like when she's putting the
when galadriel is putting the helmet on
this big pile of helmets in the sand in
the comic-con
uh release of the trailer is like
you could see how the design of that
helmet may have morphed over thousands
of years to end up to the helmets you
see at the battle of helms deep
and it was like well you know that was
kind of cool i like i mean i don't see
the
lack of effort
and and and or low effort
costumes and sets
haven't they've been developing this
like five years as well
they're about they're about 2017 and
2018 wasn't when the actual deal was
suddenly started developing
and definitely 2019 they would they they
were they were deep into development by
2019 that's three years ago
yeah i mean
the the
pre-production has taken a very long
time
yeah well i mean that they that's one of
the reasons why this is filming season
two
yeah
pretty much back to back
now the other thing that we're plagued
with
is that during uh the production of lord
of the rings
i don't know if you guys remember or not
but peter jackson would publish
production diaries
in real time before
um any of this hit the the screen i mean
he would go backstage and he would show
you know metalsmiths at work making
god knows how many sets of chain mail
for the rohirrim
you know
uh tooling like custom tooled leather
you know and uh is just because he
showed all that in pre-production a lot
of those have been saved and you know if
you get the the dvds with the special
features
all of that material is in there
and uh so it's so we also so but now
uh bezos and and
amazon prime is very secretive so the
only thing that we have to go on i mean
back in the day
i mean peter jackson just couldn't keep
his mouth shut about it but today
to do i would say
well
let's see jack black who was in uh peter
jackson's king kong
yeah
they did production diaries for that too
and he said are you sure it's okay to
see my wardrobe
i mean we haven't even released them i
mean jack black's talks about how crazy
this is to show anything are you sure
are she is the set behind should we want
do we really want to show the ship
you know i i really and he was just and
they go yeah yeah yeah yeah sure sure
i i i understand them awful way of doing
it they want to trick people and they
want to do twists until they don't give
too much away but this talk and there's
so much detail and so
i would have thought once people started
coming out and and and [ __ ] steering
i i maybe would have gone let's go the
other way let's let's release stuff and
let's talk about enough
yeah give them something to like ground
the work for them
anything
because i mean they see a bunch of
metalsmiths because they obviously are
going to have to have a bunch of
metalsmiths and leather smiths all these
different people uh
show us that's that's free marketing
that you already have to be doing so use
it
i wonder if a lot more of it is in green
screen more than i mean
so much of it was in green screen for
the original trilogy wasn't it so
um
maybe not but
it's just you know like all the scenes
with tree bird with tree beard with mary
and pippin on it you know that the the
the tree was actually a uh
it was actually a real set but the set
behind knows he's walking through the
forest you've got puppeteers moving tree
beard around and you actually see mary
and pippen swaying
you know they shot they were in that
damn tree for so long i think one of the
one of the actors actually got injured
in the screen
because of just sitting in the damn tree
so long and the seat was so small
that would have been invisible
yeah i i thought you were going to say
that um three bid was real for a second
i'm disappointed they said there was a
puppeteers
sorry i just assumed
how big did they go on the inch this
time because there are ends in there and
i'm waiting to see those things in the
trailer yeah we got a
this much little grab
yeah yeah yeah
after the battle of eisenguard i really
wanted the the uh the the game the the
the uh
hasbro whoever pulled out the the toys
wanted to come up with like a an analogy
with with the incentive but like like
you would see with green army men like
all sorts of little green like like
charging forth with
you know with the throwable troll or the
excuse me the throwable orc that you
just with the orc tossing hand features
just nonsense they're spending an
absolute fortune on this for a reason
there are a lot of characters 22
characters lots of different story arcs
and things going on apparently um but
you can see in the advert
that this is not lazy production
exactly i think it's very
okay
um
i mean the thing i would compare it to
maybe
if you're very compared to
something maybe like the witcher
um is it like similar you know like
swords
and a similar sort of style for
production it's far more i mean i love
the witcher i think it's fantastic and a
massively expensive expensive show in
itself yeah it is level above that i
mean you can see that from the the three
minutes and 50 something seconds that
we've seen
it's different level i think
here's one that's totally unhinged
the the claims that they are stealing
visuals from other sources
it cost a billion quid i'm just i'm just
going to keep throwing out that this how
much this costs
i'm not like eating gold flakes like oh
now let's have conflicts i have gold
flakes let's look at ten thousand
dollars of bespoke now we've got a
billion quid so when i change things
down
i get complaints that well you know that
about
you know rivendell would have looked a
lot more i looked a lot different
based on what
well then
you know they're
you know the the flavor you know the
aesthetic style of rivendell as in the
uh things of power
is not the same as the rivendell in the
lord of the rings but like i said before
about the helmets
you see it you know you see a growth or
a change in the aesthetic
well these people this group of the
aesthetical challenge of individuals
seem to be that's just stealing because
it looks like you can still tell it's
rivendell
but it's different they they lazily just
said rivendell looks like this when it
was the same [ __ ] city as in lord of
the rings i mean they did
yeah
it it
from other sources and the other sources
are other tolkien sources
right so they took the special effects
from the movie is that what the
accusation is
or or the the the aesthetic i think
because there's no there's no overlap
you know
this is
um
city isn't it i'm not i'm not up on the
thing yeah
right so they're basically immortal in
there
yes but they live for thousands of years
so why would you think this city would
change a great deal
in their elves dude they they you know
they say you know they'll
yeah so but also i mean but you'd expect
some change
but okay
okay natural change over a thousand two
thousand years i know we're what in the
in the second age uh maybe getting out
of the second age somewhere close to the
first
it's a lot of time between then and then
uh
that nature does things you know
you still have you know elrond you still
have galadriel yeah
they lived in the same place
yep we're allowed a couple of immortal
and they were the the family allowed
that
they're very strict on other characters
they're not allowed you know i'm just
one we're not going to get many wizards
and things apparently i was just
thinking
well maybe
oh i thought the tonkin family said no
there's not many with oh i suppose you
could have one or two but it's not going
to be a central part of the story like
it was with
it was like
yeah because they didn't
there wasn't
oh
oh thank god
the americans retain control
robots
or programs
do you think we'll get
wizards maybe not in a season one or two
but maybe a little further down the road
i think we get one early on i don't
think we don't get one early on but like
jay was just saying do you think they
won't be pivotal till maybe a little
later
so there's the meteor
okay
so the um
remember in the crater where the the
meteor lands is there's this guy right
that comes out of the meteor
and and this is just fan this is just
speculation
no one knows
but they're wondering if that's how you
know one of the velar
blizzard
enters middle earth is in a um
a meteor
or a ball of fire
yeah
because they all kind of crash down in a
similar way huh kinda yeah i mean it's
not well it depends on and this brings
in another topic later on but depends on
what source material and what book or
what you know uh
manuscript that a tolkien was playing
around with well let's do it this way
let's do it that way there's
there's also um
a
thing that the meteor may be um
and also in other parts of tolkien's
writings
like unfinished tales and the volumes
and volumes of notes he made
there was you know a meteor that came
down that was that where two evil swords
were created
and we see one sword
at least the
one sword in the lat the comic-con uh
trailer
that shows this
one of the swords of the nazgul being
coming being built from smoke
so i mean there's that interpretation so
maybe it could be that but we do see a
guy crawling out of a burning crater now
it could be another burning crater
that's disassociated with the meteor but
everybody saw the meteor
you know the elves the dwarves the the
the hobbits
saw the meteor
then we see this guy
coming out of the crater of the alleged
meteor
so it could be we we just don't know yet
superman interesting you hear me am i
okay oh my god you're yes you're you're
superman crimed out of a crater and he
was a kryptonian so
superman
i'm i'm thinking we could get the the
blue wizards
is my guess because that's just what
we've heard i hear say you know but i'm
seeing my fingers crossed
because we've never seen the blue
wizards yet
unlike anything
we know they're there okay we can't
catch a little bit
but we're not going to get any rattagas
man i'd love to get some more out of gas
but i don't think we're going to get any
rat again lame lord then he was a high
as a kite wizard you gotta love it my
favorite cotton is
a good guy
yeah it's just right these books so much
more that i i'm you're just saying words
where are we on on the list sorry
oh so the um
we were complaining about the many
changes from the source material and
lore which was well which one
again you know tolkien he wrote volumes
and volumes and volumes of this whole
world
before he really wrote the hobbit and
then he went you know really hardcore
before he did lord of the rings and then
later he
he did more and more and more and then
you know the silmarillion came out i i
know that when after the lord of the
rings came out in the 50s
there was a call for more fleshing out
of the history so he wrote like 150
pages
of just history
yeah um
led zeppelin to sing
okay well i'd say what this is supposed
to be based on because i wrote it down
so it's supposed to be based on north
mythology it's supposed to be based in
part on the silmarian which is the
uh
however so the book he didn't finish the
the letters to a biography humphrey
carpenter that they got hold of that
they and then obviously these appendices
which the half the book
um so i mean
there's a lot of source material there
but there is no actual sort of
canon as such they're taking bits from
lots of different areas and building a
collagen they have
well i mean you know
peter jackson did the very same thing
true
i mean you know
the uh
the the the destruction of uh
sauron you know the losing of the ring
i mean that i mean that was not in the
hobbit that was not in lord of the rings
i mean
that's
what 10 15 was
a little under 10 minutes
telling the whole story a [ __ ] ring
up until you know
bilbo's complaining you know in his
cabin about you know the sackville
baggins i mean he spent a lot of screen
time on just telling all this stuff and
he compressed it down let me i think
he's like eight minutes maybe just come
just squeeze the [ __ ] out of it
volumes
volumes of uh
books
which is
hopefully we'll get little inklings of
you know
right
alfredo louis that's my friend lou in
the comments actually
this would actually be the perfect thing
to start with lord of the rings on just
chronologically
because
i'll say it honestly if you're gonna
watch it chronologically
watch this then the hobbit then lord of
the rings everybody always watches lord
of the rings then the hobbit movies and
then they're disappointed with the
hobbit movies watch hobbit stuff first
so you're not as disappointed as they're
still decent
yeah you're gonna you're still gonna be
disappointed yeah and then you're gonna
watch the lord of the rings and your
life will be changed forever so that
that's the good order to watch it okay
you shall not pass
i like that bit um
okay is it i'm just gonna dumb ass
question now and just so you can yell
hate at me if you want
is the the because it's called the rings
of power so is this point of the series
supposed to be how the rings got made
i would say sorry
okay okay so i mean i thought maybe that
was like too obvious
so i assume then it would end with the
the battle that we saw at the start of
the trilogy then wouldn't it
would that be the point
maybe
maybe well he's again going back to that
first eight minutes of the fellowship of
the ring you know
you know you hear galadriel uh going
over
narrating how the rings came to being
and you know how many were given there
was nine gifted to the world of men
uh three to the elves i forget how many
to the dwarf lords
and but that was
way way way back you know
i mean if you want to know about the
source material that you know just like
what
tolkien wrote and is available
you know there's um
the silmarillion
unfinished tales of numenor and middle
earth
there's um
the book of lost tales part one book of
lost tales part two shaping of middle
earth the lost road and other writings
return to the shadow trees in a vision
guard
um war of the rings sour undefeated more
gorse ring the war of the jewels peoples
of middle earth and goes on and on and
on you know and it's
he wrote a bit
about all this and a lot of the stories
are conflicting he'd re write different
versions oh okay
dude do something that's almost like
history then because we get lots of
different versions of history is that
what he's going with
like sorry yeah
yeah
i remember he did all this just so he
could you know he he developed his own
language that's true and the only reason
he wrote any of these was he wanted to
use the language
that would be that that's that's the
only reason he wrote any of this
was because he wanted to use the
language that he invented
okay so the the guy was a note taker man
yeah
i am loved the lord of the rings i hated
the hobbit as soon as the dwarf started
singing i was like no that's enough i've
never i've never watched second and
third
really
never watched them
i got about 30 minutes into the first
one
then you missed the most the best part
at least for me
was during the battle of the five armies
with a flying angry bear
best part ever
where bjorn jumps off the eagle and he
transforms midair into the bear
angry flying bear you cannot get better
than angry flying bears isn't that the
director's cut only
maybe i don't know
i've only watched a director's cut
because i'm an absolute cena yeah no no
it adds a little bit of necessary
content always best oh my god angry
flying bears that should have been on
the on the movie poster
nothing more than tom bombadil with that
just give us the movie about them we
could have had a movie with just tom
bombadil and and
give us some bomb deal you see this is
where you know
don't eat okay you got me started so
this is where peter
[ __ ] up with the entire series the
lord of the rings
[ __ ] man five minutes a bombadil would
have
just even in the director's cuts we
didn't get bombs just put in the
director
yeah
have some high school kids acting out i
wouldn't [ __ ] care
that way andrew give me some marmodil
welcome andrew thank you for joining and
becoming a member of sidetrack you
absolute legend harris um we do have a
rule here don't set store me off
yeah we don't have any other rules you
can't say the c word covered and you
can't set stormy off it's not loud
unless somebody in the comments does
angry flying birds flying bears
um greetings cuddle monster here right
so source material this is based on vast
source material um the family were
heavily involved and somehow managed to
get
400 million dollars off amazon and keep
uh loads of rights that they were
allowed to refuse certain things and say
no certain things and apparently they
did a lot and they got the final say on
a load of stuff as well
the family was clearly involved in all
aspects of production yeah i mean
somebody with last name tolkien
yeah which i guess is also a token
scholar
i would i would argue that that just
happened to be related to the writer so
anyway
um okay so what's what's next on the
list again that's another one that's
right gone bye bye okay
the next one is just
what it is a wtf moment in uh
[Music]
in like hate clicks man i mean it's
it is made for a gender subversive
ideology
oh we're getting into the woke okay here
we go
you should get some sort of alert
message
we're now going to be discussing
wolf
and the only
i mean okay so the the it's
some of the woke things is the the
color of the skin of the actors
yeah
it's just
and so then but this is
gender
quote gender subversive ideology of the
rings of power
and
the only thing i can i mean i've been
looking for it dude the only thing i can
they talk a lot about galadriel
right it's like
you know she's a badass [ __ ] right
i mean right
there's there's a few characters like
that in tolkien though that are
strong powerful
women and and you know it's
but galadriel
modi
think about what she is first she's an
immortal elf
that's badass to start all of the elves
are badass to start just right there
that if you're an immortal who's been
alive for thousands of years and you're
just in that culture
we've seen what the elves can do
they're all doing some cool [ __ ] they're
flying off of trees shooting bows
they got their skills down pat and
they've had the time to hone those
skills every single one of them is going
to be cool in their own way i don't i
don't think that's
reaching by by any means not even
it's nonsensical i don't know
that's just this is wild
yeah and so it's
the gender subversive ideology is just
you know where's that coming from
i mean galadriel i mean it was she
she saw the original
silver alien trees and it just
i just don't what's the issue with the
female dwarf
then because we don't see any female
dwarfs in the
in the first trilogy do we i don't think
no they're mentioned but we don't
mention
well we don't know if we don't see them
or whatever someone says we see one at
some point and like i mean it's like you
know there's a some there's some female
aurichai and somebody was all offended
about that back in the day
yeah gavin i have to explain that
comment so sorry mate i don't understand
do you mean because she's pretty
do you have to explain that comment why
can't you portray a strength in the
books rather than makeup
i i don't i don't if if he's saying if
she's just good looking i think the
actress is just naturally fairly good
looking because she's the type of
actress that'll take it far enough where
you don't think she's good looking
anymore if you've seen her little 824
film from two years ago saint maude
oh oh it's terrifying it's horrifying
she she'll go places
she she would let her selfie dressed up
as an orc like that's the type of
actress i believe she'd be so i don't
think
she'd
like make sure i look good on set i
don't know i think
if you clarify that first gavin i'm not
i'm not concerned because putting actors
in tv series obviously is like
the way that works you know joe was that
joking um
was it uh that arnold schwarzenegger
movie
and the kid goes into the
film
what's it called oh the last action hero
and then he's just like uh why is
everybody so goddamn pretty he's not
thinking we just played very sexy and
five five five from the
no because of her power which does not
have to be battle strength
she's an elf though and then when we see
that in the original movie i mean um
they're already like one of the more
powerful elves and it's kind of
yeah i mean live tyler's character
literally like
the ocean
so i mean strong female characters in
this in this franchises yeah i mean you
know yeah
she you know heroin face down the witch
killing himself with anna and his eight
little terrorist buddies and she was
just a mortal human
okay so we have a question so what does
gender subversive ideology mean
i think we're already clear that we're
not 100 certain um
i mean you know
like lord of the rings galadriel is a
different one she's kind of standoffish
she's giving her hair to dwarves you
know whatever
but in the earlier books you know in the
earlier um
notes
and this is just not just for galadriel
but all elves elves were really
dangerous
you didn't [ __ ] with elves i mean
remember they went to war with all sorts
of people
and um
gladreal was one of the
i guess the generals i guess
yeah i mean she was she
you know she would she was always
scouting she was always on the watch
when other people gave up or poo poo the
idea this this this ancient evil uh who
cares and she was like oh bro you know
but you know one thing about the elves
in tolkien this goes back to why was she
was so pretty
uh the i mean talking himself i mean he
is just the elves were a fair
and they never got dirty i mean if you
look at legolas
you know gimli's
filthy dirt clotted
you know personages you know legolas is
all perfectly clean
right and so when sarah men dump the
mountain of uh and snow on them while
they're going to trying to get to
trying to get through ass
you know everyone else is coated with
snow but legolas
is walking on top of the snow yeah very
people
have seen that yeah
yeah yeah
yeah gender subversive ideology let's
try to explain what we i know a lot in
woke we get a lot of this thing about
how
female characters are just powerful for
the sake of it rather than having any
sort of growth they just always do the
absolutely perfect thing and generally
making men look stupid in the
in the in the process that seems to be
quite like rey character in star wars
seems to be that's that's the accusation
towards that quite a lot that there was
no development in her character she just
became
the super powerful
um and again
yeah
yeah um which i i i argued with because
i was saying she grew up we got to
remember where she grew up
and then actually when she starts to
that we could talk about that but
actually starts developing the force
powers you can see that the actress is
actually very talented and she looks
scared out of her mind for most of the
first half of the first and second film
but
um i would argue but yeah so i i i think
that's where we're coming from with this
um again gavin oh anybody wants to get
into that if they if you mean a bit more
than that please let us know we'll try
and untangle it but
basically but in this in this case
though isn't it that that she is an
elven and she we do have that history of
that and she's super powerful because
she is actually like immortal and an
elven which
they all are
wasn't that fair
i i i
i again you know we're we're trying to
to figure out what hate mongers
are thinking you know a lot of times
that's not exactly an easy task
because these are people bitching about
things they have not seen
yeah for the sake of bitching
that's exactly what it is they have take
they might not have the rights to
silmarian a silver mara alien um but i i
do believe they have taken this this
project is inspired by that and they
have been allowed to do that and that is
part of the agreement the deal that they
are they've been allowed to create a new
story or not a new story but they've
recreated a story from lots of and
they've been able to take from all of it
and create something
it's like elements of lord of the rings
were had came from the silver eliot yeah
but it wasn't the silver alien that they
filmed
yeah it was kind of hard to talk about
any of this without going back to that
original
story it's kind of like the codex of it
huh like like in general
the similarities kind of like the codex
of lord of the rings
yeah
it's yeah it's kind of the pr uh
predecessor to
uh certainly lord of the rings and the
hobbit
um and i think it pre it goes back
farther than what we will be seeing in
the rings of power
yeah yeah
so let's let's let's talk a little bit
carefully delicately
about um
colors uh you know black actors
basically let's let's just say what it
is i mean lenny henry who is an actor
who i adore he's a comedian i adore you
guys right now because he's a british
guy um but um
he did a tv show called chef and it was
one of the funniest tv shows i've ever
seen he played like a really stiff chef
sort of thing and um
he brings out this like michelin star
meal
and he was really angry all the time and
this um one of the christmas can i have
salt and he goes on this rampage just
google it after the after the show he
just has a
rampage at this guy
um about salt salts
and then tells them about how this meal
and just screams at him for like five
minutes and then he just sits there and
then the waitress comes in because he's
your salsa and he's just uh i hate you
with the i hate you with the passion of
a thousand fires and i've never
forgotten that
i actually use that that quote quite a
lot i've actually pretty sure i've used
it on lives before i hate you with a
passion of a thousand fighters
and then somebody else goes i'm glad i
didn't ask for any ketchup
on another
but lenny henry is amazing um and he
plays a half foot half foot half foot
elder
um
harford hobbit
come on man let's get with it
[Music]
um but that is if i understand correctly
um tolkien said that they were add
darker skin
so we're good on that one as well yeah i
just gotta say like tobin literally has
dark-skinned people in his books
sparingly of course but
is it bad i don't think it's bad to
catch more people i don't know
especially
i mean i just i just
don't give a [ __ ] about the color of the
actors
no i don't
i mean i just just don't well the
executive producer quoted as saying let
me find her uh lindsay weber one of the
executive producers
um
in the stories of um
one of the metaphors of one of the
points of what we're supposed to learn
from the lord of the rings is that
um let me find it races do their best
work when they leave the isolation of
their own cultures and they come
together isn't that kind of the whole
point of the lord of the rings is that
they have the fellowship and it's
alvin's and men and wolves and hobbits
and they and that they they can only do
it together
yeah i mean so but also let's remember
that this was written between 1937 and
1949
in a very difficult
but this is a modern retelling of a
different story that's not based on any
canon we know of so
why is it a problem and
if they didn't have that it should
represent
at least an element of real life and
remembering this is based on north
mythology but it's not based in norway
in the 15th we say well
where older
um over here in britain we had a
retelling of uh
robin hood
and they made um made marion um a black
girl
um are you looking all right this is a
stupid question asked life am i supposed
to say black am i supposed to say
something else i don't know i can't keep
up with it let's at least stay with
black black okay thank you
and was this actress american
no no no she's a british guy just a
brilliant act really pretty when she's
just phenomenal um but they nobody
actually batted an eyelid at the time
and they actually there's a few comments
about
were there any black people but then
actually some historian came out when
actually there was a lot of black people
in medieval not not not a lot not like
you know nothing but they were it wasn't
unheard of to have there was still
immigration particularly in the uk
because we were a mongrel nation we
our we our power in the 16th and 17th
century was based on trade
so
you know to see
somebody from africa somebody from there
wasn't completely unheard of
you know um
[Music]
it was probably it wasn't it was rare
but it was possible
um
but they did it because they picked the
best actress and they you know they
wanted to mix things up i suppose but
nobody really bothered about it nobody's
really that that fussed
they did it in merlin as well they did
it to retain a merlin and king arthur
they just brought in some
various actors you know
i don't have a problem with it
so let's let let's
flip that around did anybody really
[ __ ] i mean there's lots of people
bitched about this movie i'm getting
ready to mention but did anybody really
[ __ ] about william defoe's color in the
last temptation of christ
no and he should have been um
i mean because that is one caucasian
[ __ ] i mean let let
his trait about better to something
i mean you know
jesus wasn't white i mean you know he
was a palestinian terrorist according to
the roman empire
can you please stop trying to get me
banned from youtube
and like
that's not called jesus a terrorist
please clip that last little thing
in terror the completely different thing
and that was in the eye and i did
preface it but that was in the eyes of
the roman empire which he was he was a
troublemaker he's getting he was
pontius pilate was kind of really not
that happy with him it was a pain in the
ass and it was just like let's just nail
the guy to some wood and have it done
with
but william defoe
not a great color and no one can there
is lots to complain about that movie
yeah i mean i remember when i had i was
patted down searched when i went to go
see this movie in a theater
years ago because it was i mean i had to
be searched for weapons and things and
they had the um
they'd only sit in the bath back half of
the theater
because it they wanted you out of
throwing range of the screen
and there was crowds out in the parking
lot and and all up and down the road
with protest signs complaining about it
after i got out there was this one like
kid came up to me tried to save my soul
and us and he said it was just such a
terrible way so what was it what which
part didn't you like so i've never seen
it before
that dude is probably some [ __ ]
now on youtube bitching about lord of
the rings and the color of dwarfs
or dwarven women or both
or everything uh
i have to set what how much swearing is
in the video oh okay
so i'm just gonna change the setting
um
i'm so sorry you got me wound up again
i know so anyway he he let let's call
you know jesus was portrayed as a
malcontent of the roman empire
now content i like malcontent
youtube friendlier
uh
phrase than
ancient palestinian terrorists
is less likely to get us banned off
youtube yet
uh and and then i was like i lose track
of what gets us banned on youtube anyway
um it doesn't take much all the time
nowadays oh that's true that's true
yeah yeah
so
right so i think we can knock that over
right well this is i know they said they
need to stick to the original material
but i would argue this is a modern
project
um and it's based it's it's it's based
on a made-up
um
world anyway so how do you know what the
six thousand years before the the the or
however many thousand years before the
lord of the rings
i i think these people getting angry and
demanding that they know what
everyone's skin color should be it's a
bit stupid
um yeah i mean it is
i mean it was people i mean talking
about the going back to the original
source material how many people were
wound up about romeo and juliet
and and leonardo dicaprio
probably a lot actually i mean that was
based on william shakespeare's romeo
juliet and do you did it look like
anything from you know
shakespeare's time
not at all it was just uh
it's a modern retelling you put up here
you know when we're yelling at mercutio
to put up his sword it's a sword nine
millimeter gun
yeah
nobody had ammo clips back in
shakespeare's time sorry but no one
complained about it oh it was a
beautiful retelling
so i mean
if you want purity in a story
don't see the movie just read the books
which is fine if you just want to read
the books that's groovy too
exactly like a book or tv series exactly
like there's just no way it doesn't work
yeah jack
didn't follow the books sorry no here it
is
the lord of the rings and harry potter
are probably closer than most generally
but and that's might be why they're so
beloved
but
they're by no means the same thing
they're no means the same thing there
are lots of films that have done things
and they try to stick
more closely to the end of the book this
is this is going to be shocking so you
know like spoiler alert and all that
books and films are different
i don't know if you knew that
um
um but it's a different media isn't it
you know yeah exactly audio books are
less confusing the situation um but
they're a different medium aren't they
they don't and sometimes you get films
that they really try to stick to
the exactly sort of thing and they don't
work and they tend to be born at the end
because books they tend to they don't
end with a the big event they they they
whatever happens and then they sort of
have to explain
everything that sounds that's kind of
like harry potter at the end of the
harry potter film is a bit weird because
it's sort of like it's a bit of slightly
odd sort of like tailing off towards the
end of the film in the book
it makes sense but they stuck to what
happened in the book so i mean it
doesn't
sometimes you know it's
you know one reason uh peter jackson
when he changed things for the dvd
version because he said you know dvd is
a different format than the movie
theater you can do more things you can
have a longer telling of the story that
will not work in the theater
the hours in the theater
yeah i would have done it though
so
you go in with one of those pee balls
i'm good
i'm good yeah i got a catheter strapped
in my leg i'm ready
we're here we're going to read the end
credits to the end of time man
i'll pretend there is i'll wait
you you brought up something since this
is psytrek you did bring up something
that's kind of
also
parallel to what we've been discussing
today that happened this last week and
that was william shatner's comments
about new track
versus
we would be spinning
spinning in his gray well you know
i don't think shatner is a literary
critic
i mean so let me put it together award
winning writer
let's
he did
win a pluto yeah yeah yeah
uh but
in the terms of the original series that
shatner was what was some of one of the
best
stories best episodes ever
in your guy's opinion um this is not a
true question
that's a couple isn't there because
the golden one is fantastic
the black and white face dude is
fantastic yeah
um
[Music]
that one was sparkling when he has pulp
uh oh god i've got what it's called when
spock gets horny
pogba ah profile that's not right that's
gonna annoy me um
but yeah those are the ones that jump to
mind uh thorian webb
dorian webb is good yeah yeah yeah
go on then first you're too young for
you
gotta say i'm i'm really not i'm not all
in tune with my star trek sadly
no
i know i'm
sorry i couldn't help myself no it was
rightfully so on sidetrack i don't know
star trek i know the new movies and
that's that's that that's that's about
all i got
him out again i'm kicking him out again
he didn't say they were good to be fair
balance of terror is a great episode
so how are you going
so so one of my favorites along with the
ones you guys have just mentioned is
city on the edge of forever
right
so yeah there's a great garden and the
guardian has been using other you know
it was used in star trek discovery
yeah yep
that was an episode that was written by
the late great uh harlan ellison harlan
nelson one of the most describable
gadfly writers
loves the sioux people
because a lot of times he was trampled
on as a writer and
he and roddenberry
really fought tooth and nail
over this script
there were so many versions of the
script that they are they both
harlan's version and roddenberry's
version both won awards
but you know of the prestigious awards
harlan always got the better one and he
went on to expand it for other media as
part of short stories and he
um talked more about the guardian and
some of his short stories
but
gene roddenberry would turn over in his
grave over harlan ellison
for what he did in the city of the edge
of forever one of the best loved
original series episodes
and roddenberry
fought tooth and nail with all the other
writers i mean you know it's if you read
like some of the original uh cast
uh uh story books that they published on
you know their time with uh
with star trek the original series back
in the 60s
you know they will often talk about the
war between roddenberry and the writers
even when the writers were cranking out
golden stuff he would say oh it's not
good it's not good it's terrible this is
gonna be the worst episode ever
you know and so if if uh
roddenberry is turning over in his grave
over some modern star trek content
maybe that's a good thing because he was
always belligerent with writers in the
past
just give me more lower decks
yeah you look loaded i do love photo
decks series three i think he'd have
loved strange new rules i think he would
have
but i i've always wondered what would he
have thought of
even the end of tng
you can you can definitely tell a style
difference when g broadway was still
heavily involved
in the next generation the first couple
of series and then when he stepped away
there was a style change and rick berman
and that sort of really
took control
but i would have i've always wondered
what he would have thought of maybe
parts of voyager but definitely deep
space nine that is so different to
hit the roddenberry track
um i i i would argue even though he
always had war in the background in the
book
yeah i mean
deep space nine is the most
anti-roddenberry anything that's ever
been produced
i mean it's
let's say i mean that was
the
you know because in some episodes the
the federation was kind of the bad guys
you know with cisco's manipulation of
the
romulan senator
that ended with the romulan senator's
death they got them into the war
favorite episode this is the great
the the section 31 i mean all of these
things is like
no [ __ ] clue what we're talking about
but uh yeah i'm intrigued though it all
sounds fun deep space nine is amazing
you should watch it
is one of the the things to watch
yeah all i know is don't watch the
places
which makes me sad because i do like
sneaker martin green
i don't know what that is i've never
heard anyone say good things about the
new one
uh strangely worlds is very entertaining
well no that one i've heard good things
about the the one with sunequal martin
green is the captain uh
that one
their discovery i have mixed feelings
about discovery but i am finally sitting
down to watch the last series before the
series
and i i have to admit i don't like it so
i'm a bit but but i think gene
roddenberry would be spinning his grave
because of discovery because it's boring
because of
any
um
woke nonsense or anything like that i i
i i'm sad to say
the characters are kind of boring
and um and gene roddenberry wrote
characters
yeah he loves
characters he's very character-driven
characters in discovery it's just dull
does it just get lost in kind of
concepts because a lot of sci-fi does do
that sometimes
yeah a little bit um i think they just
went in a direction they decided in a
direction but i mean the problem is i
suppose they it is a character issue for
me with discovery that they have a set
of actors and characters and they
decided those very early on
and none of them are particularly
interesting
and they've never been able to quite
sort of do a voyager
um
moment you know when they bring in seven
of nine or
uh even tng where they sort of it wasn't
quite working so they really they killed
off to share and re-jigged it and they
got it right and
um or even deep space nine where they
bring in the fight they've never quite
had that moment for me where it's sort
of like
almost every star trek series the first
two series don't quite work but they
find their footing sort of thing and
they're halfway through the second
series and they get the phone that's
that's most sci-fi shows
they find their foot in the second
series
um
they've the discovery's never quite done
that for me and it's still it's
beautifully made some quite good stories
even though i don't like the stories
either but i think stories
um
but it's now it's a character issue for
me
they're boring which is why strange new
worlds
i'm actually not a huge fan of the
stores and i'm really worried about
where it's going but the characters are
so good you just don't care
that's the one with uh ant and mountain
right yeah yeah okay um
you know it's just that the characters
are just phenomenal but just they're
just an anson mount is beautiful and if
they get rid of anti-matter and bring in
kirk that idiot look
um
i don't like the only one the only one i
don't like is the actor they've brought
in for
kirk i don't like him
he means forwards like this as well he's
sort of like he's like hunched over when
he's in his appointment but
it's um
you know i don't i i just don't like him
but
we know he's in the second series this
maybe he's not in the rest but let's see
what happens
but yeah i love strangers
how did we get into this still do we
talk a load of drunks
i think we've covered all the rings
don't we
are we good
i i think we're good the uh
mattress
68 uh had a good point about amazon
ruined a wheel of time
with wokeness
the i don't know if you the wheel of
time is a whole other
multi-thousand page trilogy by robert
jordan
and a couple of others that filled that
uh completed his trilogy after his death
the biggest problem that i saw and and
mattress may want to fill me in with
some of the other issues was uh one of
the main characters moraine
was uh having a sexual relationship with
the american seat
well you know and they say oh that never
happened in the books well the books uh
phrased it as they were pillow friends
which i would say was a sexual
relationship
and later on the widow of uh robert
jordan said well yeah
and that's what that means so
in my opinion the the problem with the
bigger problem besides moraine sleeping
with the seat
is that
amazon did not go anywhere near where
they needed to go in terms of budget for
such a complex
fantasy story they did spend a lot of
money on it but they did it
either they didn't seem to push it
they didn't seem to push it and i think
the acting was was good the writing was
okay
but it really i mean
the the the pace was much faster than it
was in
the books well
it was mostly about book one and there's
13 more to go at least
but yeah i think it was the budget i
mean it was just
you know
and uh some people accused amazon being
racist for casting peyton feyne is with
a black actor i mean like the whole
reverse of lord of the rings it was just
you can't escape
but i think if there's a problem in
terms of a wheel of time
it was just a lack of budget to really
do it serious justice and it was i
thought it i loved wheel of time
um i discovered it in book set when book
six had just been published and so i
just went and bought books one through
five and it was just
awesome song i didn't think it was crazy
so the time was coming
okay
but i didn't watch it didn't it didn't
catch my imagination wheel the time that
that's where i was at i'm uh i'm just as
big of a fantasy nerd as i am a sci-fi
nerd at the end of the day and
yeah if a new fantasy show the second i
saw witcher i jumped in i mean yeah yeah
yeah that wheel in time would be
something i would do that too but it
just it never works
and i think amazon
might have done that slightly on purpose
because of the i i only got half an
episode into carnival row but carnival
row was the fantasy that they tried
right before it uh
and that was
if carnival wrote another go i don't
know if the second series is coming that
there was supposed to be but then
covered and i'm not sure what's going to
happen there but actually carnival rose
one of those um series that it got
better
by about halfway through the season
you'd be hooked i actually genuinely
really enjoyed it but it took two or
three episodes to say that first episode
was i tried to watch it two or three
times and it was just like it was bread
yeah it
took took a little while there's a
series on there at the moment is it
i forget what it's called
that's a similar sort of style to that
um
i can't know what it's called but yeah
my kids have my lads watching reading
the books
and that's a similar thing i couldn't
get into that i tried but i couldn't get
into it but i'm not kind of where i
actually really enjoyed in the end it
just it just took a little while it's
it's a slow burn
um
i got pretty much cooked by cove it's so
many other projects i've just got ruined
my coat
i don't think he said cooked
yeah but we're going with it because
we've already i think we've had our
quota
um
so anyway with lord of the rings we've
got yeah i think wait to watch it people
yeah
and i but i actually think it's a loud
minority that that are shouting about
this at the moment and to be honest
it's a stupid argument when all you've
seen is three minutes of the adverts so
i would say
and all the same people that are
probably screaming the loudest are the
ones who will be the most pleased if it
does do well
which will either
give which will make them angrier and
make them maybe double down or we'll
just shut up i'm hoping i'm hoping
not necessarily shut up you always want
good discourse around the show
is it people is is it with some people
and i would i would say a lot of the
subscribers we a lot of the people i
talk to are really simple and they you
know they do think these things through
but they see all the videos i think
at least in part just really worried
it's going to be crap they love it so
much and they're so nervous i don't
remember what it was like when the
movies came out but same thing we were
all frightened i'm like oh my god
someone's gotta got a license for
tolkien you know we always going back to
think rethinking the ralph back sheet
version of the hobbit we're going oh
jesus christ
you know but
one thing that's really terrible
probably the the number one fan site in
terms of tolkien is the one ring.net
and they have
the the guy that runs that
yeah i mean yeah he is that guy has been
around forever
and uh there was an article in his uh
put out on may 10th of this year
uh is titled the rings of power footage
draws high praise from tolkien community
and jay i think i sent you this link
earlier
you put it in the show notes because
this is the
the scholars the the people that are the
fans that are really representing the
fans and not these creeps that's just
looking for hate clicks
that actually saw the episodes and what
they you know
you know they took the tour of oxford
and all that stuff
and if you read through what the
one ring.net their editorial on this
event because they were also invited to
it and all these other scholars and fans
hardcore fans that the community of
tolkien uh freaks like me have learned
to trust over the years
and they are they are
loving it you know they a lot of the
fears that they had like we all had
there before the fellowship came out
loved it they don't have those crass
things that
people like at dick watch
on amazon oh excuse me youtube put out
all this hate click stuff and it's just
these are the people who've actually
seen it so doesn't it
the people out there doing videos about
woke
this is what trash this is where it
crashes they get hundreds of thousands
of views
honestly
all the top guys do anyway i mean
because there's a lot of these videos
and it is that i mean people love um a
bit of controversy they love a bit thing
but i i i kind of i mean i'm on the i'm
in a bit of a thing with the woke thing
i i do think there is an issue with some
um politics coming into
some tv shows i just don't think it's
anything like as big a problem as some
people make out it is
i do think there's an element but i also
think this it's always been there but i
would actually say bad writing
is a bigger problem
yeah
that's what's more stand out than a lot
of the wrong things because i think
the quote unquote things that keep
coming out people complain about that
that do have bad writing that maybe have
lost a little bit of quality people are
focusing primarily on the politics of
something instead of the story which
doesn't always
a lot of times those things coincide and
if the writer can make them coincide
they're doing their job right
my little alliteration there uh
but
it i feel like the bad writing is
a lot bigger of a deal in the wokeness
of things currently and that's what
people are focusing on and
honestly wokeness is synonymous with bad
writing to me i i'm telling you jay we
really need to do a series oh i didn't
mean to step over here sorry no no
you're good
i really think we need to do a show or
series of shows and just like
gunsmoke was woke
it takes shows that are beloved by every
john wayne movie ever it was woke
um
my clint like
woke up
someone who talks about sean connery
nowadays
yeah yeah just taking the these these
shows and characters from yesteryear the
golden age of radio and just you know
sometimes when i watch older movies and
you sort of realize that they're talking
about stuff we're still talking right
now but they'll be talking about
environmental issues or something in the
movies in the 80s and global warming and
things like this we think oh i thought
that was a relatively modern
thing you know maybe you know i'm not 40
50 years ago we were talking i'm
surprised or you know like um things
like this so i was i just think we
we we remember
what's more what's going on now we talk
about this but actually i do wonder if
these these conversations are the same
obviously woke is a new term
but it just but we forget the bad
sci-fi and the bad movies and the bad
you know things don't we that there's
some things that are the hollywood's
just just churning out crap now
and then yeah but in 10 years time
we'll have forgotten the crap that's
made now and we'll probably look back
now and go oh you know the golden age of
dvds or something um the golden age of
cinema they used to they released a
movie a week
the mgm and all these things
but we remember the good ones cary grant
did like about 90 something films or
something like i can name five or six of
them that were actually good and i'm a
cary grant fan i love carry on but i
mean but he made a lot of films
most of them were trash
um you know but but he made some
absolute gems you know it's like we but
we forget the rubbish i just wonder are
we having the same conversation that
we've been having
forever we've got a new term for it that
makes sense
back then you know no one really went to
go see a movie twice
until star wars
now people don't remember that i mean
you
uh when my grandmother found out i went
to go see it twice and well you already
seen it once why did you go again you
know it was never done
you know and so the reason they had to
put out all of these movies is so they
could get more money because it was
you know the shows were ephemeral you
know if you don't have a movie coming
out that week in the box office then
you're not going to have income for that
week
you know it was insanely competitive
and um
i think she's i i think mickey's got a
point that's gonna end yeah that's kind
of what i was trying to say bad writing
is
but people
the whole thing with woke as well is
it's a very simple thing for me is that
the writers and directors have always
reflected their politics in their
projects
that's always been the way
um i don't think amazon are telling
people we really would like to um push
lgbtq
community this week if you could do a
story it's a lot it's the writers and
you've got to remember it as well i
don't know you guys i've met a few
writers actually you guys have
definitely met a few writers they're
almost all hippies
um
that need to be hit with a stick stop it
hippie
um you know it's just like uh you know
and that's what these these they're all
very liberal and very you know
um so
but that's that's that's that always
been the way
i mean yeah how old is uh yeah i mean
look at uh
stephen king how old is he how many
books has he written have you read his
number hundreds and loads of short
stories
i mean he stephen king really gets uh
triggered by anything that
you know
uh trump fans or magga or january 6th
was
best time ever in america i mean you
know stephen king is
he's a writer and he writes beloved
stories i mean [ __ ] man he's pulled in
tons of money but yet he's
hippie
or he's accused of having hippie ideas
um
the uh
going back to the gunsmokers
it was either an episode of guns and i
know i'm dating myself there's either
the episode of gunsmoke or bonanza
and i'm thinking it was gunsmoke where
there was this asian character that a
bunch of drunk cowboys
stole this uh chinese man's cue the his
long ponytail
and you know and and so they get to get
you know matt dylan i think it was mad
gets the guys
you know they returned his ponytail
and the the the chinese gentleman is
says uh yes sir no sir and he's got this
kind of crazy subservient
uh yeah uh one wants hair back yes yeah
well i was just you know all this kind
of
kind of racist cringey but then when
dylan gets him off to himself at the end
and he returns the cue
the chinese gentleman turns out not to
have the whole
jive talk going you know he was like
thank you officer dylan i appreciate
this
and he's got this whole kind of
intellectual vibe he's just a smart
human
and
dylan says well what happened to all the
you know
chow wanna
wanna tear kinda what happened all
and the character is explaining
that's the person they want me to see
they don't want me to see me be smart
and hence gun smoke woke a dressing back
in this black and white i think maybe
his color i mean it's definitely 50s or
60s
and so here's gunsmoke
talking about race relations
more than a half century ago and we're
still bitching about it today
you
know
wasn't woke i i do joke about that but
actually it was a little bit
a little bit
you know
but i think that's
for me that's the best thing
racism still a massive problem in this
country and and definitely in america
we've have a divided europe we've
divided america
um sexism is still
a problem
um there are still men that think women
that they have very odd ideas about what
equality means
um
but racism is a massive problem the
lgbtq community is
it's confusing for a lot of older
gentlemen i i
you know gender equality and i say i
find it confusing but i can still
respect it
and i want to i want to understand it
better um
i'm not going to stay here and say i
understand it because i don't but i
don't understand the thinking i come
from a psychology background and i you
know i struggle with it but i can still
respect it and i can still put it but
it's reflected in our television because
it is such a massive problem in our
culture at the moment and it should be
yeah
anyway i'm getting a lot of naked ladies
for some reason it won't let me block
you um an error could i keep trying to
put my time out god damn it well here's
you know
this is probably something we'll discuss
uh later on is like the umbrella academy
you know which one has elliot page
instead of ellen page
and one of the more brilliant
discussions i've seen is like we're so
many people bitching well uh i don't
who's this elliott person why the [ __ ]
should i call him ellie i don't know
that's ellen that's ellen
you know and when we meet somebody says
like hi my name's timothy but
phil for my friends call me tim
we grant timothy the respect to like
call him tim
but for some reason we have to
disrespect the person that doesn't want
to be called ellen and instead wants to
be called elliot because that's who they
want to be called as why is that of the
prop why is that the stink
and timothy gets a pass
i mean i said i see that as the same
analogy as just you know
like harris could be one be called harry
or harrier or whatever
harold
harold
good old english name
or jay could be j ford
jafar
the word
jason
you know but he know what i get a lot
send me this i did somebody did this
venus my name is actually jamie but i
get i got jay but um jamie lee curtis
was the only famous jamie when i was a
kid so i got a lot of crap for it and
there was a tv show called jamie and his
magic torch i got a lot of crap for that
um shows your magic torch
okay
not that you're perfect um but um
luckily there's a few more famous jamies
now but um uh but i'll get but um but
what's your actual name
jamie because what yeah what's it short
for
jamie
but what's on your birth certificate
[ __ ] jamie
it's not james no it's not james why
would i call myself jamie if it was
james
and
i got that a lot it's so weird yeah yeah
he said just just a little bit more
about me
um
so yeah
yeah exactly i i would say that even if
you understand there's always that
respect and directly contracts your own
thoughts and beliefs i say it's not
about my my my basic belief structure is
very simple
um
you can do whatever the hell you want as
long as it doesn't force your ideal or
hurt somebody else yep
and and i don't i'm not more complicated
than that to be honest i don't
understand things there are things i
don't like um but that doesn't mean i
think it's wrong
um i just i just
i just don't understand i don't think
but i but if you want to do it i have
absolutely no problem with it you know
it's just like that and that's that's i
think my basic ideology and everything i
mean it goes back to just live and let
live
you know yeah
love myself love my neighbor uh you know
it's just like you know jesus said there
was two commandments and i've always
i've always stuck with that that'll do
me
you know it's um
[Music]
going back to the umbrella academy real
quick though i thought they handled that
super well uh i mean i don't know if you
saw season three or not yet jay but uh
no i haven't seen
i will watch it do you know what doing
this channel i get to watch a lot less
sci-fi
i'm so busy
between
doing this i can't watch the thing i
want to watch to talk about so i have to
like stay up really late at night
watching stuff
uh but solar opposites is worth it if
you're still having that domain okay
that's all my list of things i watched
this week
yeah
you want to segue into what we watched
this week jay yeah let's do that and
then we are going because we've gone
past an hour and twenty eight minutes
storm
i love it when early you said i'm sure
we'll talk about it later i'm thinking
no we won't
so i did watch uh the first season this
last weekend
uh school offices i mean i just yeah i
got two more together but oh my god we
have to be busy with a new job i am
that's yeah i it but i i i made only 20
minute episodes thankfully well thank
god
but it was golden man i mean
god it was good
and so i kept all also persevered with
the resident evil series that is really
good really good i am going to disagree
with you
i've i've not heard you're the only
person i've heard say that's good i've
never
cried any other news is good about
brethren i thought it was a really good
orange or more detailed origin story of
uh
it was um you know what it's like it's
it's it was very much done in the style
of 28 days later or you know like
a classic zombie so i get if you love
zombie movies you gotta love zombies
first off okay and because that's a
style of i think i think they've
actually done that on purpose the way
they start it's like
classic british um zombie movies that's
how it felt to me um the problem is i
don't like classic british zombies you'd
have enough simon pegg for you is that
right
so yeah
i i i watched the first three or four
episodes um earlier in the week and uh
no not for me
so i also finished up i watched the
season finale of strange new worlds
finally got around to seeing that
excellent i thought
um
i watched the latest episode for all
mankind on apple plus also done by the
same guy that uh
uh wrote was the story runner for deep
space nine
oh really right yeah yeah yeah uh more
yeah did for all mankind and this
because i've heard only good things
about deep space nine and i've only
heard good things for about for all
mankind as well yeah i mean he also did
uh outlander the romance
yeah yeah the the time jumping romance
story oh really excellent i always loved
that i always did that i also watched
something that's not really sci-fi or
fantasy uh but a binged dropout
it was the story about
uh oh
okay so yeah it's the story of elizabeth
holmes the fraudster they created the
company theranose
or surrounded from however not theranos
yeah
yeah fairness
it was a company she pitched as being
able to diagnose all sorts of issues
from just a drop of blood
and it was
almost a billion dollar fraud
ever i mean it was
four times she was until she got caught
i haven't seen the last three episodes
but she's she does really well
was the where she starts kind of
changing her vocal inflection because
she tried to imitate you know the story
jay
i i i know a little bit of the story
here but i don't watch seriously
the it's it's good and it's taking me a
while to finish it but it's it's good
it's a great actress so tell us the
story about why she changed her voice
it's a lot of people's long run now oh
yeah yeah yeah uh
because she was trying to imitate uh
god don't don't apple ceo
it's not not tim cook
that's the one i'm thinking of
uh and she just she dressed like him and
started uh changing her vocal inflection
to deepen her voice to try to sound more
masculine and stuff and amanda seyfried
from what i've seen so far just watching
the process it's just so yeah
the you know and to me when she changed
her voice in her mannerism she said god
it's almost like she's jody foster
yeah right
it's like
what
you're
watching an actor become a different
person
it's great and when we when you said
that you look like tim cook there was
another thing i watched this week was
that was on my list was a jurassic park
dominion finally got to see that meaning
good
i haven't and
dodgson
really reminded me of tim cook oh yeah
that's who he was based on
he's like
god is that i mean he's a how long did
casting have to go to find that guy
or with you grown in a vat to look like
tim cook just for this role they they do
put a lot more effort into this sort of
thing nowadays don't they find you right
i was about to say
that movie is all right it's it's dumb
fun
but don't think about the sci-fi aspects
of it
mount is the character of uh ian malcolm
was the best yes goldberg no blooms just
that was it just watching for the beers
bro it was
golden
yes oh
i watch resident evil i've started
watching stargate series three sg1 again
because i'm going to do a video on it so
that's what took a lot of my time up
and down me to watch that i'm not good
halfway through sg-1 season 3. still in
the first time stargate love it
everything i've seen so all right it
gets better and better uh
yeah i've i'm through a fourth episode
in
so i just i just love it and this is one
of the weaker series gets better for me
gets better after this but anyway so
yeah
i did watch resident evil but i got a
bit bored by it
um i watched prodigy finally
um so i really enjoyed that
because i got paramount listening
and then
so finally
and uh
you know i watched a couple of marvel
movies because i watched um
the new marvel movie uh was it
got sick
love and thunder i watched love and
thunder
and hated it
um which really disappointed me so i
went back and watching it and i just
don't think after we did we talked about
a lot last week to me so i went to watch
doctor strange two again yeah
so um i just i actually um i didn't
watch the end
i haven't got quite to the mirror
universe yet they haven't killed captain
britain yet but um i will watch the end
of it probably tomorrow but
it's really disappointing me
didn't like it so i need something new
so i think i'm going to watch that thing
you mentioned
nope earlier i i i need to watch nope i
need to watch nope
everybody is saying that is the seminal
um sort of sci-fi movie that's like our
1001 a space odyssey it's our
uh of the current you know i think it's
it's it's like it's it's going to be
it's a modern classic it's like an
instant modern classic apparently
um so i can't wait
i don't it's it's
damn good in a lot of ways but i don't
know about
instant classic
it's because
get he made get out and get out as
instant classic in my book and he
there's a reason he won an oscar for
that real quick us it was decent i liked
us but it entailed
this was almost the anti us in the way
of
i thought us was awesome that first half
and then it kind of just got boring and
it didn't get boring it just didn't make
as much sense uh the second half of us i
don't know if you all saw that jordan
peels yeah
this one
is slow for the first half there's
definitely interesting things that
happen um i've heard a lot of people say
that 15 to 25 minutes could have been
cut
probably
i like
i don't love the exposition per se but i
i like the things they talk about
because it's kind of it's good nerdy
stuff you know
halfway through the movie turns it
it it i'm not going to give it away but
it turns from
horror movie that's kind of like
ethereal in a way to
horror sci-fi
and more like action horror sci-fi and
that's that's it it gets a lot of fun in
that kind of that was the one thing i
was told was that there's two or three
different genres going on here
and it's like um somebody said to me if
it's got a feel of like cloverfield
to it in places
that it's sort of like they don't really
know what's going on
and that's part of the point sort of
thing but um but yeah no i'm really
looking forward to that i think it'd be
good um it might have to be a dvd though
or you know while streaming service
nowadays because i don't think however
much
i lie and tell my wife it's about
something else i don't think i'm going
to connor into going to the cinema to
watch that with me
um
it's worth it if you can catch it by
yourself or or with the kids or
something i should just go down myself
i'll go with myself one day after work
actually i've got i've got an odin card
and i can go as many times as i like and
i never do so maybe i might just do that
i might just skype off i might just
leave work now early and go watch up so
why not
um
so what did we think about the uh marvel
announcements this week
good titles
the titles
i mean
they're kind of we were bitching in
avengers movies i don't know how many
avengers are left
but we've got a couple of avengers muse
yeah yeah only mostly dead or turned
evil
it was uh
what secret wars are gonna be that's
gonna do you all know the basis behind
secret wars
no do not
there's avengers and then there's oh i
do reminds me i do know this
i've read the comics and i can't
remember
it's uh
i'll i'm gonna butcher it of course i'm
gonna go i'll generally loosely say it
but it's like essentially
multi it's all these multiverses coming
together and having to fight each other
and yes goes to blame kind of who's
going to be
the real one i don't know i don't i
haven't read the comics all the way so i
couldn't tell you if they're
yeah but what happens at the end of the
day i don't know if all these different
multiverses end up getting to live in
their own retrospective universe and
fantastic four is really central to
very much
particularly as it gets later on the
fantastic four are really central to it
which is why we're gonna have to get
more stuff but the fantastic four movies
also been announced first
haven't we got films through to 2028
no
and secret wars comes out 2025.
you know the biggest still admission
a hulk movie i just cannot believe
i mean come on i know they don't well
the rights but
come on
well
what's next month
she hulk
well
yes but
what what big event like sdcc uh that
just happened the comic con uh
next month d23 is happening next month
and for phase six they only announced
what uh
fantastic four then the two avengers
movies at the end there's still six lots
of films and or tv shows that need to be
filled in that timeline time there was a
rumor that they might be able to get
around the contract by doing it as a tv
show because apparently the contracts
does say quite specifically
that they cannot use hulk in a
stand-alone cinematic release
so that was the one rumor that it might
she hulk might move go into
i might set up
world
uh world war hulk
so i'm a but it would be
a disney plus release
um i don't think i think i think the
disney plus i think the tv series are
great i thought maloki was brilliant
but
they would have to put a lot of money
into that to make that work
that yeah that's my biggest
hold up on she-hulk as well is
everybody immediately was poo poo in the
cgi which of course wait till it comes
out also yeah yeah they can finish a lot
off coming
so let's
let's break this down because they would
they announced
secret invasion guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 season 2 of loki which i'm really
looking forward to
echo iron heart
agatha the covenant of chaos
have actually already been announced
i guess that we knew about iron heart we
knew about yeah there's captain america
new world order of course
daredevil and thunderbolts and
fantastic war king dynasty secret wars
the multiverse saga
in wakanda forever
not one word about star wars anything
did you guys catch that
actually it was very much a marvel week
wasn't it it was right and so is the
next is the next convention going to be
all star wars not one what's going on
today is there anything going on today
at the comic-con
that was getting on a jet going back
home i guess i will find it now just it
does run today it does run friday
saturday sunday isn't it
additionally i think saturday is
normally the big announcement day there
was yeah i think traditionally speaking
but it was comics
i mean you know
it seemed like fantasy was on friday
comics was all yesterday i was hoping
for a nice sci-fi sunday but i mean
googling here see if they
mentioned anything still early for any
announcement it won't be till like
uh two three o'clock isn't it normally
when they
aren't at disney's official um
star wars instagram it was just like the
lego summer vacation
i don't expect them to say anything
honestly you know what the star wars
projects are though don't we we we know
um
a two or three of the tv series we know
taikawatiti
what the hell he's going to do with star
wars i i just that scares me to death
now after watching
yeah um yeah i'm completely the same
with you i was just like this is genius
you like you disney you are so clever
and i'm like disney you've really [ __ ]
this then he's writing as well which is
just raymond that's like we said last
night yeah
just a little bit just enough which i
think the executive producers will
they'll still say it's gonna be a star
wars movie if you want to
hopefully um
i mean for in terms of disney
announcements i think it was the the
biggest thing that they talked about
was the uh national treasure
that actually seems interesting yeah
they seem to be pushing
they do seem to be really pushing it and
i'm a little bit surprised nick cage
isn't in israel on the direct isn't that
a couple of the producers still trying
to trying to convince that's the one
thing that i i find intriguing about it
is how much they keep pushing it as like
this is already a good series go watch
our series but we still want nick cage
even if it's only for two seconds we're
going to get nick cage if we can have
nick cage find a way to get him yeah and
i think this will be the only project
he's been offered he's not said yes to
he says yes to him
honestly ever since he lost all his
money that man has done he just worked
work
fantastic though the last few years i've
really liked him he's doing some good
projects classical yeah i still haven't
seen his last film with them
unbearable
yeah i really really want to watch it as
soon as soon as i get something i never
quite got a chance at the cinema
um
the
the you can almost see the cogs spinning
in stormy's brain i know when storm is
building up
um
the one thing i uh oh i was gonna say
something i just got out my brain
actually started talking in the case oh
no i was gonna say i've got symptoms and
dragons
what's that
dragons that does look good i'm looking
forward to that
it felt like what a real-life board game
should look like
yeah i think it looks pretty cool um i
actually really loved the
very camp um movie
20 years ago
um with the terrible actors and oh what
was one of the brothers was in it was it
wasn't those um
[Music]
brothers
yeah um i caught like an and jeremy
irons just so bad it was it was
generally a little bit creepy
being there
he hated being he was there for the
check oh yeah no he hated it didn't he
but i really like that movie um
the kid the kid that starred in it he
was in some tv show before that which i
forget the name of but him i always
thought he actually could go on but that
i think that film completely killed his
career but he actually did pretty good
job
except for the drop into his knees no
after his um after snails died
um
you remember the guys characters
but um
i really liked it but i think this is
going to be a serious movie and i'm
hoping it's going to be a franchise on
that thing but it looks pretty cool
i i i'm very intrigued and happy with
the cast they got i think yeah it's a
good effective group of people that look
like they're having a good time so
that's always
if they're having a good time i'm sure
we can have a good time with it too yeah
everybody have a good time you know
people get [ __ ] up
there's another trailer came out this is
over on apple plus
uh the final season of jasmine jason
momoa's c
and david hulitzen isn't it this time i
think or is that the one that's david
it looked
awesome i mean they discus they
rediscovered the trade and they [ __ ]
[ __ ] up with it
but it i mean again it sees one like is
so original in terms of an idea i mean
it wasn't you know it was like
actually original and it was
i mean uh
the first episode of season one i was
just captured with it i mean it just
and it's but this is the final season
they say
really and the journey ends the story is
complete i still haven't watched it i'd
love to try it out it looks
if you get apple plus
yeah you gotta watch just that i'm gonna
get it i've saw the first season adored
it but then my apple plus subscription
ended and i'm not paying for any more
subscription what i'm gonna i'm just
gonna get it for a month and binge watch
two or three projects
sidetrack needs another new email you
know
yeah
you can always get a new subscription
whenever uh you get a new email
if if apple plus would like to send me a
subscription um as well i'll i'll i'll
talk i'll talk very positively about all
apple process programs to say of course
i'll just say you're gonna make a fake
email every time you need a new uh
monthly subscription
oh yeah i should do that shouldn't i
there's lots of ways to get up and get
around these things and i can't be
bothered with any of them so i'm so lazy
well i just think
i just think just i'm i'll just be a
complete sellout and if anybody just
wants to send you know send me things
and i'll and i'll tell them they're
brilliant regardless of how good the
quality they are or not well did that
got enough zeros or whatever
my fans that are really looking
the the best uh selections on apple plus
for you sci-fi fans is a c
uh
foundation which is like foundation oh
god i'm already and i've been waiting
since a child for that to be made into
something i mean it's just such
it was very clever how they did and how
they how they handled such a broad skill
now it doesn't follow the book so don't
get pregnant about it
yeah yeah yeah
and then of course for all mankind i
mean there was some great science
fiction over on apple plus and pl and
other things that aren't science fiction
yeah
got a binge watching
right chaps we are pushing two hours
look at him look how small he
hours i got stuck for two hours
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm going to build a lasso and mythic
quest or two i'll tell you what if an
american wants to learn about soccer
they should binge watch ted lasso i do
love to excuse me
football
oh yes well uh what's your name a
co-star from ted lasso is gonna be
hercules at the end of uh he popped up
at the end of thor
that's right oh yes of course
little kid in the mcu now
um
what soccer isn't and i'm going with
soccer because i'm with two americans
and i'm trying to be respectful for your
stupidity
okay football because i actually use
your feet in it you idiots so no i love
you all um
but yeah
it's it's
it's sort of like the counter thing is
it it is so ridiculous in hinds
but um i know i love that series i love
i actually like that actor he did it he
did a movie a few years ago with him
jennifer aniston which i really liked
we're the millers
we're the millers i love that yeah maybe
the best comedy in the last decade i
love that movie because it's because
it's actually funny and then um
and then and jenna franston does that
striptease
which i'm still like
hello
you know magic brings up another great
show uh uh farscape
i mean you know it is like i've been
binging old sparscape you know it's just
the story's still there you know if you
want to do muppets or you don't want to
do muppets either was fine but you know
for me that's like in the same sort of
bucket as um andromeda
yeah this is serious that you know we
talk about we have so many reboots and
so many remakes something about so at
some point somebody will make andromeda
and somebody will remake
foreign back in forescape they would
have claimed forescape was woke because
it really did challenge toxic
masculinity they're athletic wasn't one
of the characters transgender is that
well one was a flower
um yeah there was a lot of you know a
forescape man it crossed all the t's and
dotted all the eyes
in terms of alien life forms
it was
damn it you got another three minutes
out of us
christ
out of football well see the reason we
call it football is we play it with our
heads you know and so we bang your head
we all suffer from concussions here so
we don't know what we're talking about
you do like the ball occasionally in
that game though don't you
kind of
i mean
yeah
american football's one of those sports
that i just i just watch it and i just
keep thinking it's rugby for cowards
and then you guys play basketball we
have netball and men are hired to play
it
um and then you guys have
baseball and we have rounders and we
only play that as children
as soon as we don't have to play it
anymore we stop
um so
okay bob remembers
rizmer sam rather than bob
rymersma
is dead on man with hyland there's just
not enough really good highland stories
out there being produced it's just
heinlein was just i mean he was like the
stephen king was that he'd write a novel
before lunch it was just lots of a lot
of his projects are quite hard to
sort of put into like a movie
in the translate would be a little bit
difficult
and and and when they do get translated
for the big screen they are horrible
like the one with john travolta and i
forget the title of it was just
where the aliens really loved their gold
and he was the travolta's alien
character was kind of just locked in
fort knox with all the gold and it was
just kind of bad
great right
the translation of the big screen really
hasn't been done well
yeah
so there's high hopes
we need i i almost
it pains me to say it just from the
couple of things that we've said
recently uh in the last few minutes but
you almost need someone to come in and
taika why td it like he did with jojo
rabbit take pick a book and then find a
better way of telling it almost in a
visual sense
yeah
i i just i don't know if i would trust
taco itty after thor 11 thunder and
we'll see with star wars i'm
hoping i'm
keeping my fingers crossed
i think that any projects by this guy it
would need to be somebody that really
really loves
the source material they can't just um
you don't mean battlefield earthquakes
that was yeah it was it yes the abortion
that was battlefield earth
oh it was horrible just oh lord it was
horrible yeah i know it was really bad
um
oh it's one of the biggest loss in
movies in history and it's about top 10
biggest loss
um
excuse me
travolta needed a hobby i guess you know
yeah well it was scientology wasn't it
he was pushing the scientology thing so
yeah
that's right that's right yeah bob's all
right yeah he's got he's got that he
he's calling us out on it yeah there's
no wrong number
yeah it was yeah that was a one hobbit
him and the one i was thinking about you
stranger in a strange land which was
really need somebody to
that'd be a good movie if somebody yeah
strange like they they've they've tried
once twice something but uh
he wrote some brilliant sci-fi and then
went crazy and tried to make a religion
and i'm just yes
but hey that's a quick way to get um
hate mail let's talk about scientology
for five minutes
people knocking my door
just living in l.a uh during like when
covet happened oh and then when when the
c-word happened my bad i already broke
one i broke both rules today
uh but when that happened on 419 which
you know mr mq movies money marijuana
over here it was the day before 4 20
which is my national holiday every year
i was i was i had an appendectomy on 419
and i uh it was
not awful i was literally in and out
within a day within a day i was back i
made sure of it because i had to be home
for 4 20.
smoking on that day was not
not my best idea um
besides that point
all the way out of uh the hospital i
guess my cousin came to pick me up at 20
a.m and we drove past the scientology
building the big scientology building
terrifying at 1am
so creepy like you could you could feel
like the the ambiance coming off of it
just was it was ominous it was there was
a giant uh
like lion that was on one side of the
building a statue of a lion that
didn't look entirely like a lion it
looks like a sci-fi creature line
[Music]
there was a my scientology story is when
i was living in san francisco
um
there's this one bus stop on sundays i'd
go see all these movies you know all
these theaters so i would crisscross the
city with on
the bus network
and there's this one bus stop you know
i'd always stop at and then somebody
would always come talk to me and just
kind of try to get me into chatter then
the bus would come and i'd get on the
bus and get wherever i was going to
i never got chatted up at any other bus
stop you know ever
and you know because you know
kind of tend to themselves and then it
turned
on my like third
stop there while i was living there is
like i look up and it's the scientology
center for
san francisco
and so when any time they saw somebody
get off the bus and wait for the next
connector
let's go chat with him
and it's like so it is
really it was just because it was the
most bizarre how are you doing are you
feeling okay it's like do you do i look
homeless did the moon fall out of my arm
why all the concern trolling
they rope you in and try to get
something personal as quickly as
possible
and it's terrifying i lived right on
hollywood boulevard when i first moved
out here right every day i would walk by
the scientologist people by a couple
months in they didn't like me because i
said a few things do them every now and
then
but i mean because they're trying to get
every tourist so every time i walk by
i'd be like i live around the corner
like stop like please uh and they
eventually got that but uh
they will talk never really go on here
we have i think there's still a
scientology building in birmingham which
is a city just up the road from me
um
birmingham sorry i didn't pronounce it
correctly for you
birmingham alabama
west midlands you know it's booming
we're gonna be blooming him um but yeah
i don't know if it's still there but it
never really caught on here because i
think like we
are educated
and when they when it's explained what
scientology is we'll go we'll go nah
you're right um also we've got jehovah's
witnesses and if you've got angry
religious people they win
um so in this yeah i don't understand
jehovah's witness i won't go too far but
if your entire belief system is 114 000
people and the existence of humanity
will make it into heaven stop knocking
the people's door try to get that spot
for yourself knock knock out
a little bit more selfish people come on
oh by the way we all do know where
birmingham is because that's where
tolkien grew up but of course oh what a
way to think i don't i don't i'm gonna
ask you in the [ __ ] would have been a
great way to end that jay i mean come on
great way to end the series that would
have been but i do want to talk about
the dark tower quickly
i really enjoyed the idris albert movie
with dark tower and um but it was just
it was just too much going on it should
have been like a trilogy
what do you think about dark tower as a
series i think that's perfect for
streaming service
i thought that's ideal i thought it was
great i loved the books and the film was
just
it's got a lot of great stuff to
to produce content off of
practically yep
yeah
i'd love to see that
anyway i'm still waiting for rama series
to be made into uh
a show
starting with rendezvous with rama that
was all
with rum i thought you said futurama i
was like i'm ready for the next season
to come back that
thank god john dimaggio i'm excited oh
my gosh right is it cancelled at the
moment or not cancelled because it
always goes around its vehicles don't
get cancelled and uncanny
again okay maybe it's just a mini series
don't quote me on that but uh it's been
so many things for such a long period
first it was just like you know some
one-offs and then there was first
there's the tv show then it was like
some one-offs and more tv shows and some
other strange things and
if there's new drama i'm going to watch
it yeah
i love that series
ben is one of the greatest characters
i wasn't supposed to watch that when i
was younger uh but of course i would
come home watch that and then watch the
boom docs and then
that's probably why i'm out in l.a now
but
right we are at two hours so we are we
are going to call it a day people so
shut up stormy do not say a damn word
do not come up with any interesting
quips or stories or any other things my
butt hurts and i need a wii
so we're calling it a day
thank you seriously guys thank you so
much talking i think we've sorted out
that the lord of the rings we could have
saw that in two minutes actually
couldn't we lord of the rings woke
garbage
can we wait to watch it first
that should have been the end of it but
um
but hey we covered it we knocked them
all at the park and then we've had
some so thank you so much for joining us
so
go over and um
i probably haven't put you in the
description i'm sorry i only got in
about quarter of an hour before the show
started but i will put you in the
description but go over and join stormy
stormy's channel is actually pinned to
the top of the
youtube group it's the a resident
american of course for president america
i'm so go find there um and paris as
always thank you so much go search
mcubed he's got loads of interesting
videos he's stoned for a lot of them but
you know we can't hold against him
that's the way to be sometimes and
ironically the two americans are really
from california
i'm about to say i'm from california i
live in california
we are residents of california there we
go we're immigrants to california yeah
california
don't
i shouldn't talk about that the hotel
california always
living it up in the hotel california
lovely place
what a lovely place
[Music]
goodbye i was waiting for it
[Music]